the fourth largest jackpot and U.S  lottery history has been won one lucky  ticket holder in Maine is 1.35 billion  dollars richer this morning following  Friday's Mega Millions draw the prize is  the second largest in the game's history  with a 1.53 billion dollar jackpot  handed out in 2018. according to the  Mega Millions the odds of winning the  jackpot were 1 in  292.2 million at six o'clock this  morning my phone went off the phone  identified it as a phone call from  Augusta Maine  and I was told that my store sold the  1.3 million dollar winning lottery  ticket  I thought for sure it was a scam  it was either going to be an ass for a  gift card or my social security number  shortly after but it was not  so I looked online and sure enough  I had one we had sold excuse me we had  sold the ticket so the media frenzy  quickly ensued down here at the store  it's been a real busy morning and we are  anxiously awaiting to see hopefully it's  somebody that we know we see often  [Music]